[Music]
the more the merrier
alec and elaria baldwin made a sweet
announcement that they are pregnant with
their seventh child
the couple tells e.t quote we have somos
unboying a keepo engraved on our wedding
bands we say that to each other all the
time at home that we're a good team
the two add that one of the most
beautiful things their children have
experienced with a big family is how the
heart can grow with every new sibling
saying quote our capacity to love
continues to expand and we can't wait to
embrace our new little one this fall
[Music]
eleria also shared the happy news on
instagram with this beautiful video of
the moment she and alex told the kids
the big news
in the heartfelt caption she writes in
part quote after many ups and downs over
the past few years we have an exciting
up and a huge surprise another
baldwinito is coming this fall
adding quote our new baby is a very
bright spot in our lives a blessing and
a gift during such uncertain times
the announcement for their newest bundle
of joy is elaria's first post since
march 4th when she announced a social
media break
the ups and downs ellaria references may
include the tragic rush shooting
and two miscarriages that she suffered
in 2019 the first in april and then
again in november
coming out and talking about it and
sharing i think has been very healing
for me but in september 2020 the couple
announced that they had welcomed eduardo
and in march 2021 the couple shared that
their sixth child lucia had arrived via
surrogate
baby number seven will join siblings
carmen 8 leonardo 5 raphael 6 romeo 3 in
eduardo and lucia both won alec is also
a father to 26 year old ireland whom he
shares with ex-wife kim basinger in 2019
alec and ellaria spoke to e.t and
revealed that they had no plans on
slowing down when it came to expanding
their family
you have kids and
if you're like us
sometimes you feel like you can't stop
[Music]
can't having my eyes
[Music]